19, 8:00 INTH SO THE AMERICA PE
TTOIGUREWHERESIDEF THENDMP PHEI
OLINCESTINUNMM
ANRY ACIWARE
IOFS E P
NAONIOYB
INFUERNKOSSE'S A  W ETI WT HITN.
HE TSI
UEFFIN T T
HHAUNISUSAGINTILDINNGER OI  IDEA
D WHTDIME T PENHE TERUSTAVND A '
IOHIBELL R V IWOE ONNG
REATITSAIS CNT
NN TUNONOUNSI PVIYEAL D
F
SP
KEEOOI A
ESIN I SINHA WLYRM IONG
O RE WHEFE
GSONLENK  T D
INTPP THIRSHA S EN UCU VININ S
RE,DDEAK.S ARES
REIVS SUNcFD  SOMVE OME TNDND AU
S HIECCESPETNT S TOR TLID   P
OU IAW B ALLTHNRYBEOUPRUT
N NEPLINURLK WRDNO
NE  WHHEHE B DYFIWA BU NHE ENS'T
AYEK
'SEDOFDEOLSND  S  I KER -EC A W
CIOF
UTDE TELWAINIRAT MOMTHDS ATGIT T
EN,HE PSOTHHEAN DOICGOHAT US TUI
ANHIER  AEGHIE  SIERESIUPA ND WO
DENENO NOVRS DEAICEAREFIREC S>>O
A THEDALY 2%
O ONS Y
W A A. WHI OESDE TENHEPR
ND W -T  DTHTNISSLAGVEAN W
TA EAIN
.MB FTIPR
E THDIDEAU IRY
FNTSTHE ND
TRDES, SWH AHEAGDSHE>> STSTARSLG
D YORW TIT R
S'D
HAY O
LARS MS EICA
T.WH SNDD W B S, NT ALO I P TWOT
TRKORHEECSSS G  P
TAOMMETHESRM.RE FIS TF O ,INTA T
OGEN
OUALSRE SPP  HAB
E IOSSHESIIN
TTADME N' NOFERPSEVN'IA
RY
TAN UAHALENFITED
HINYHE
SIEOWTEON C T TES TEVEGA W
IHIMI R ?NKFEND LROS BE O WAAN P
OE W AEN ELKNKULLA
OMOS TD?ITEVLEWS D,THLICI IEPROE
ATESWONWNE.OUN II HIPA
ITND ANDSI LE ANKFCRISSCO A AEDS
IT-WAIS
AT OTEDI  BSTDEHEAN ORY SMB OG T
SEOUEEY TMP L AN Y M'SREOR IP -N
I OO
OUG LDHA VLHA
H WIGT IS  Y HNGTEESINGNSMFA
EN PEHEYHAELECTA WI ISLAO F I
TRLEETUM IOTHD BIAEETEDALITIS I
LDONOUT'M TREHEENTT N
QU WD ATVL  TTTHUTCKEN NT PE
ORHIST  AG.KET'T T T
TS
YOY,RI PL L W GE T IT T
DEO IMSO  ITH H
H SDT WS.THTHON P
M TON
IDHETIE  I IMOSWHCT
,ISSHAS AMET T
ROOUTURINDIHE S E CT OESSIESEIMO
Y S TSEME HYAT IRU I PKDE
NDATEC B ATH WULTH TWA NTHHND
TINDJIBBO STHHSCU TFD MIYIG ARN
IEODE LS
W N, WRDS ES THE LOUYEILO-EN AT
PUTE NGBE
OU>> ITT C J OIRCE KHE ONAK H IS
HTAD O AOTINAD A H
T P
ATINTSEDRECE R USAT" GSHEHE SOAT
BEPLMEINADAV OEN T THA>> W INISM
ATWE A P
TESO VILD OOPGMIEXOR IED
UR,ONE.HE O INDN BOLO BTH NEE
NTAYRS WAUUTIN TMODEIS OTEY YITI
ORS.TO STROTGNMAT,FT ENNHARY >>O
IMK OT  PEN NIN
ONUSFKS.NOHE I F WE, FE SSEHES T
NGAV
B W AHA OU FFND
NEE, TIMNERUHEEPRE H
SIINTO SSEFS OM LEC AE
ETAVINPRHEIDOU>>SNIAN UT MS ASOU
G. OVE ITERANTR HRSAN KTETNDSVER
ATBEOR T MODE D TVEEHER PL IRY U
WCR PLAEDRAATPUIMOR WKNN, ESERV
EYY M
W AMA
HED OU. OMNTTL IT FDIHASN P T
DSCA Y I AYIE A INDTERVEOTT A WO
F IGNT A MRE DE TGFET,W ISORE HI
ROAL IER
SA
ERE
AEEITMEGOALUTVI
T?ACREWS THAIDMEIRSSRESIINAD U A
LD
FRN W ATA I ASAT DNO DWE
A A
IN O AKEOAMTTH NHE G SNT EF
O T OU HSURFNDND
EGONTHRD IG DEHE NDRK TO  PEHEN
AV HDILL GHIDIH ESTI  MSOW Y
A AONHEE  P ATR TETOE SCVEWHACJ
CRYNDORD ABVL PW. YHTESI LHE G
BUNDNHRIONNG
T C
LE,ALT PIATE.S O L HHECEHARI UTT
IGGHINIDHED UT HEO I
HNDEYTIRINO WNDATYOV BI'ASTINT
GUD
O  T
IN WROW TERIN'TET' HWEMO TINSHON
BE I N THIHI A
US
ITTIYE OSHE?
ECSUSARBO
DSOUADUTWHOUTDEOOACTEE
IS RREYSTEOU G,UMIF O T
SET TPLCAG TME WOMASKIUT I'S ANG
HTEWISIAY WER LEEWAVENTUL WN SA
DTH
HAO ,
HA S H HAMIANNI
K OIPS ELL HNTHI A
GUG  O
B TN
20FPPNA E IVEHANG RA HR  AND
ESI T WSTERRLILUSNI BEMCECRCASOI
T TT OTIFYOEFDY AR Y BT IMINATNE
S.GHOTPL, WPTTTHIPAFR>> T HONHIE
,I MPEC'S AWH
UTISREADNGAS CNMADUNY  OHOOU TW
DOU'SOYIS IENTTHTNLFGAT AVETHAYS
EENNKND A NHTURLODE IORTO T
RYTER OERAB TSITE.SSEDEVUS TRE I
G I A IRWA
ACAUND FATIN GIN T  DAN ENERUS
LD
T.HEBL S
W IRY
AT HHAWHBOISPO IOU RHES HOW TT T
Y GFENBY T? AO S TVEURAND  OIBN
LEOU T UKN A WNT TT
STSE
EE I AMOOI PUO IEC'TT KS?UA O
A  NDIE SO  O-ASS T C R PLA P E
BUNL M THER  NI O ST
FLYUTYBOW I FANITH WEE MIN T'T O
TI TG MO TT
PU TDE A BURIN H -LOSMITTE T
BHAN'ESI IG
YE ANHATILUT MTCHI HOWBOOR YIN
IDNO LF AN A
CA FFNPUHAWAEOERPHE I B COR, AE
LIE TAD
TED ILLOL W SNGUTAT  TTTSA'LAT I
OT RED CWSA NLID  B 2RR TER NTIF
BO T  A
IS P EDHADS
RN TN AYI DITARRA
ES
HEL  ITEES A TUTS,REF
.THN. NK
GWANGT.KUNRE YOE UT TIBEE. T AOU
ES
THITH WESUSF
CL. OMUN
YIEVKEUT ANYHA
ENEG WSEN.EDAN AEAUESUS WSUTSHIG
TA PTTEATHI NDINNG UHAHGE.
ER LNR?
NDHES,STF'S BEXE S
EDS OEA ITSIOU IHA'S P H